[Music]
thank you
yeah important thing is I'm talking
about today about customer visible data
of your visualizations that's an
important attribute for the joys of
Technology later on yes or imagined I'm
a data scientist I normally work on
back-end stuff like arrow and Pocky
I'm typically around with Python and C++
I'm not a typical your eye guy but there
are things you facing to do in your work
life and sometimes really good nice
things come up in the talk I wanted to
show a bit why do we actually want to
have these dashboards why we actually
have sometimes problems building this
dashboard which extend a bit more than
just building software and how we got to
compromise how to have effectively build
these dashboards with everyone happy in
the organization and at the end I want
to share how really done technically
with some code normally we have data
science product we have machine learning
models and we have also uses that use
this machinery models and they are not
tech people there they don't understand
what our models do so these models are
black box to them and for those we need
him to present those visually what
actually happens what is the output
what is the machinery model doing this
maybe even helpful for us as data
scientist when we want to understand
what is no model doing on a high-level
perspective there's a something where
you need in a UI a dashboard if you have
also tasked what you want to do very
often even if you attack people and can
do to use the command line sometimes
it's easier just to have a UI where you
can click for visualizations then you
really want to build something and
waiting you're fast fruit and also as
already mentioned there are lot of non
tech people so petting an API which is
easily usable is not possible if just
some major or for me it's grocery store
major
I cannot use an API they need something
to click but also my talk is a bit about
building an end product for customers
first it's data scientists there's
already really good toolkit which is
pure Python where you can use it ok ok
it's a blotting library but also book he
brings with it
ok server and you can use boogie server
to build - dashboards which directly
interact the browser with your back-end
code so in this example you you just
creating with these 15 lines of Python a
web page which has a bottom on at an
input and if you click on that button
routine on your back-end is triggered
which then also again ran as now put in
the front line and that's all code you
need to generate this behavior on the
right hand side that's really nice if
you're a data scientist it's pure Python
so it's perfect for you so you don't
need to learn a front-end code but
actually this is not something we could
have used in our environment because
we're not all data scientists ok it's
great but it's an environment to write
in purely Python that's the main selling
point of it but it's also one of those
disadvantages of it because we have
front-end developers run and developers
can make us really awesome UI's they can
really start and really good but are not
Python developers they develop in
JavaScript and also everything that's
around and if you give them - they're
really armed I don't want to use Python
and then also ok doesn't really directly
render in Python code but there's also
some JavaScript in there so you have
widget in buki which then in in the end
are generated by Python code that
outputs JavaScript which gives a bit of
interaction and makes it for front-end
developers a bit harder to do this and
if you have a customer UI you really
want to care about the usability in the
front-end and how how easy your
front-end developers can extend it also
you can use poke a say your front of
developers uh
- working - then you still have the
problem that the Brocade the front-end
library introduces its own set of
JavaScript requirements and these are
not so sandbox as a front-end developers
would like them which also makes the
front-end developers a bit angry then
but though if you don't care about the
front and UI and you just want to write
a dashboard that's for you that's for
your data science team you're probably
really good of using book hey server but
as we're building an product we need to
care about front-end developers
front-end developers they have their own
ecosystem and they want to use it and
they want to work in JavaScript I want
and working in CSS was maybe SAS HTML
and so on they want to use the
dependencies from the ecosystem they
want to use the newest data stuff that's
available and they also don't want to be
constrained for us and also they would
like to have minimal dependency on the
backend and then when you give them the
freedom they can build your widgets
around your visualizations user
interactions navigation navigation menus
and the really really productive but
that's all only happening if you don't
constrain them too much so you need to
find a compromise between you being able
to do everything from the back end and
your front end developers and being able
to really style your I one of those nice
things to skate separation is Vega and
Vega light Vega is in itself just a
taste Jason specification which you can
use to describe plots and you can
describe an awesome number of blood
so all these visualizations up there to
just render out of this Vegas
specifications than Jason and it's
really white crema and because of that
can cut complex
there's also Vega light which is more
high-level approach which you can use
for plotting and charting and where you
have to write less expressive Jason
statements and still get a lot a lot of
lots available with it which has the big
benefit you have a protocol between your
client between your Python back-end and
your JavaScript fondant to push the
good visualizations forward and back and
you have a really stable standard which
can rely on but in the end you as a
back-end developer also have will want
to develop some prototypes and also want
to develop some prototypes in that
ecosystem that's why your front end
tests also have to be a bit careful
about what they pick we in our case we
picked of UGS which is one of those
trendy very odd number two front-end
development frameworks Vega is cool for
you we are plotting your visualizations
but for all the widgets are around you
need something else it doesn't have to
be huge yes it could also be reactor so
the important component in your is it
should have capabilities that you can
start simple so that if you have PI or
all the data scientists can then maybe
in five minutes or so push up at first
prototype and also integrate something
in it it may have to write one or two
lines of JavaScript but I shouldn't know
any deep knowledge of JavaScript or a
framework so the basic requirement on
the front-end framework also has to be a
simple level for a deep for the first
prototype it can go deep if you're
really being doing fancy stuff but at
the beginning it should be simple as a
short demo yeah
sadly on the wrong screen
yeah
so javascript also has a nice framework
around them and its package manager NPM
is also not only a package manager but
also controls your environment you can
use that too
so it also has this development
environment its framework and his
package manager also also DS a bit about
environment and scripting which gives
you then at the end when you build such
an app with with kind of DES advanced
JavaScript frameworks you have one
command normally like view in it and
then use the name of a template it sets
up a project template and then you say
npm install and you have all your
JavaScript requirements installed then
you have two entry points normally you
have the template it will give you some
headings and their space to input your
your widgets and the code that controls
your widgets if you're only doing your
prototype which is not about styling
you actually can really really far by
not doing so many things you can't just
run what they have the template and push
run the really nice thing about
JavaScript it has hot reloading hot
reloading not just it will not just
start your web page totally new when you
change something your background but it
also it will only chose parts of a
website and you which you changed when
editing that's something I would really
like to see in Python it's it's probably
much much harder to do this because in
the front and you can just see your case
justice this one box and we have to
render this one new but it gives you
really fast feedback and development so
you normally don't have to restart a
server
and as we do in Python we also have to
do start a Python server to get this
demo app up I'm not I'm going to show
you the code afterwards we're starting a
Python flask server simply that runs on
the back end and will serve us some plot
some plots that we later on and
visualize in the UI
and keep this a bit in mind this is now
the demo which now how much code is in
there it's a simple template which shows
here how vague a visit looks like it's
really simple one I have picked to put
in a demo data set which shows you a bit
of comparison of how farc
Automobile can go compared to it
horsepower it has and in the backend we
just randomly generate this data so we
have some plots to see how it behaves
and it gives you a bit of interactivity
and also it's UGS is a mighty framework
and you get really really simple lines
of code i'm already some some things
like a control bedside which you can
expand and add a menu so without writing
any code that's an important thing or
you just write a bit of your template
and the framework in the basic way
connected for you
now when we want to see a bit of code
I'm not 100% sure how much you can see
of that code as already said a Vega
specification is a Jason snippet so
writing a Python back-end server
actually it just means you had need to
have some server returns a bit of JSON
in in the backend in this case here I
have a simple flask app just four lines
to inner life the flask app and then I
called Jason Lee fire and a big Python
dictionary which then returns a plot
which in the browser looks like the one
on the right hand side so the rendering
is all done in the browser we just made
this one Jason it's quite a handy if you
have a simple small plot the inches
could just write the Python dictionary
and use that but in the end that's not
totally handy if you have moderate her
if you have more complex plots and for
that there's the newly I'm partly new
library alter recently had its 2.0
release which brings some real nice
features to it like better concatenation
of plots also what I'm not going to show
but it's also a really nice feature of
this Vega things and you also can have
interactions in the plots so if you have
multiple plots and you connect them
together you can pan and zoom and these
plots also then are connected and also
assume the other plots without you
writing any extra code which is also
really a nice feature if you have a UI
and your user should be able to select
on the front-end a bit about what
they're seeing and want to drill a bit
in into detail if you have alter you can
just simply put this data in a panda's
data frame pass it to the charting
library and called true lines of code
which then renders the chart as in as in
python dictionary which then is passed
as jason to the browser or even better
if you're in a Jupiter log book if you
run this one line and it's the last line
in your cell it will also just search
short so there's already native
integration for Jupiter and madam I have
shown is made up of
three snippets the first one is we have
a flask up the flask up in the backend
it uses from Vegard as a cast data set
we just used it an example put it into a
data frame so that I don't only get
always the same plot I'm using the data
I'm calling out here and say please you
know generate me in X Y bar chart
scatter plot and just randomly select
one of these columns I specified which
are portable columns and I get a nice
scatter plot in the front and which here
makes me my full bag and app I'm going
to talk a bit later more about out here
the thing is now what we lost we're not
using something like bouquet
I also offer Python only front and
dashboard libraries we lost a bit that
we impure pipe so we have to trade off
we have to use JavaScript our front-end
developers and are really happy because
that's where I live my fellow data
scientists are not so heavy because
they're not important but the really
good thing is normally don't have to do
so much things if you write an a proof
of concept which they affirm it
front-end developers will hate her on
evolve to fully fledged customer UI and
this simple example we have a part where
we write JavaScript so this is all
JavaScript I have written for the UI
which I've shown the first line says you
going to import Vega embed Vega embed is
a library which just takes its jason
specifications and this place and
visualizes them in the browser at a
point where you specified it and the
special idea but view is you have a
dictionary in JavaScript where you
define all your methods you will call
and we have here one method it's called
reload image and we will call this
method when we click on the button which
I mayn't reload and all of this does it
calls our endpoint which is my my cases
Vega example and when that endpoints
returns response it pauses it with with
the Jason Plaza and I'm positing that to
Vega and bad Vega ambert takes three
arguments the first one is a path to an
HTML element in my case accorded Vega
box the Vega specification or the bigger
life specification
in this case it's Vega light in normal
case because most of Bloodshy do with
all their simple plots it can be
rendered with Vega light airy ant I'm
setting also some options in this case
actions fault normally if you use Vega
hem but it really also put you three
buttons at the top like a few sewers
save and something else and that's not
something if I make a custom me I I
don't want that that's really nice for
debugging or if I'm in my Jupiter
notebook and I can inspect what Jason
was generated I can save the image also
but if I have a customer your I want a
bit more control about what is shown and
my non techie users are not interested
in the Jason service lot so I don't want
it lot at a front end with those buttons
and then to render at all the front end
we had we have a template which also
gives us the menu which you don't need
to write we have to put there the button
under and a box where we can put our
image into which basically means we have
we put our container and also in the
example that was already a slide
transitions or when you close and open
the menu on the side it gives you a nice
transition I left that in there to make
it a bit more code but in the end the
essential things you need is internally
there's a layout and layout means I have
a box in the middle of my page and
there's a button on there which is
called a V button here and we've had
clicked or native I'm saying okay
there's a routine that should be called
when I click on that button and on the
line below I have to book the element
called Vega box this is the one I'm
using then to show my image at the start
of the page is just a placeholder once I
click on the button a visualization is
displayed this is already for me as a
back-end developer doing these
visualizations enough to get some input
normally you would also put some maybe
one or two input elements in there
because you're not only sharing one
visualization there's always fix it just
needs to be reloaded or
probably you have some input in your
model and you just want to select which
after the input should be used and
should be displayed maybe you want to
tune some parameters and change it and
then you get this output I'm there but
it will be that you write two or three
lines of you code and then you write
maybe two or three or five lines of
JavaScript code and in the end you have
your proof of concept if you want to
have more styling then in your front-end
you also have to invest in JavaScript
this is always your choice but the
important thing is we want to write
something here were we where -
developers and JavaScript developers can
coexist and can create a really awesome
product this example it's online I will
also put the slides online then you can
click on the link there's also readme
which steps you have to take to
reproduce the example showing it to you
it's easy as a JavaScript it will also
be a bit amazing for you because it's a
simple example but it will probably
install about 800 dependencies or so but
that's just typical JavaScript use case
and don't need to be care about that
much and that's basically how you build
a UI which is suitable for Python and
JavaScript developers both but they also
I've used the RTL library and the other
libraries really cool so I wanted to
show you a bit about your library and
examples now I used again this cast
dataset and you need these three lines
at the top to get example working
there's also much much longer attached
tutorial and you could make an O a whole
long talk about out here and so also
click on the link look at a notebooks
they're really nice and they also share
about something is about interactivity
but alter is its best on the idea of the
grammar of graphics which is also enough
to talk about in a whole talk but the
basic it gives you a thing about to
incrementally build up a plot so if you
doing an out here chart you normally
first say to it I have my data which in
this case is my data frame called cause
and I want to have a
in this case I say mark point and I
maybe have 20 columns in my data frame
but I just said mark point so all the
plotting library knows to do is put a
point in the middle I can then say okay
then used for x-axis miles per gallon I
get a scatter plot one-dimensional and I
can vary it I can say market ich which
gives me a sticks instead of points but
from a foreign example I would stay with
point you can and say okay give me a
y-axis this is horsepower it just adds
the suit you and you get you build it up
incrementally by adding attributes and
seeing directly to change by putting one
in it never again way and you can also
say I have then used my third column
origin to color my scatterplot the nice
thing is about Vega and out here or Vega
light and out here what you doing here
quite maps to what Vega right is doing
internally this is also building up into
chasing specification as a grammar of
graphics there's some more amazing
things down there like you can also do
aggregations inside of out here we just
and unlike for the browser this is
really nice if you have one or two plots
connected then when you zoom in one plot
and both plots are connected it will
also just select this data in the front
and then but it also means this amount
of data has to be able to be stored in
the front end and only the aggregations
on a data that on the front end are end
on so short summary we went to isn't use
some technologies to build you eyes that
make everyone happy not just a Python
developer but also the back end
developers we talk to each other that's
also how we got to this stack first we
had five developers suggesting one stack
and JavaScript developer suggesting one
stack both being unhappy but a good
thing was we talked and we got a
solution so if you also have these
problems just talk it's the easiest way
and also if you're selecting tools think
of that who all is in your team not just
what is the best for you so what's the
best for all your team colleagues and
also our chair is green eyes it's not
even you
I need it for your eyes mostly it's also
used in notebooks just try it out it's
easy to use and it's also fast so that's
the main thing of my talk now I was
should do 10 seconds of advertisement
for my colleagues which are also doing a
PI data and culture so if you don't know
what to do in October you forward okay
Amsterdam was cool but I want to see
other parts of the world so country car
through call for papers is open until
midnight but there are rumors it will be
extended by a week so even if it doesn't
know about this potato and culture now
it may be even possible to write and it
never talked and that's it
[Applause]
so we have room for questions yeah so
the very widget that you showed in the
in the view code what so Vega is a
specification it's also a software stack
or they guys specification of a certain
software stack how does it work
Vega is a specification and there's
JavaScript libraries implementing how
its rounded in front-end said the same
team it's the same team but it's not
totally the same team I think the people
doing the spec are making their own
renderer but they're also alternative
renders like there is we also my fondant
developer said okay you're using Vega
it's using canvas in Peru but as also an
alternative renderer using WebGL or SVG
in a browser which then has maybe better
on mobile also so that's not there's not
only one thing that renders them in the
browser okay so it's a pretty decent
standards for for graphing yeah
thanks for your talk
wonder the question how would you
compare Altea too closely or is there
any comparison possible between two I'm
not 100% sure what blocka told us that's
my eye
I think godly has like okay it has a
kind of back-end so everything and it
also just as a plotting library it's
probably the same like okay
if it's if you do a lot of things in
there and you're all generated with
Python code in the backend then your
front-end developers will have to dive
in into the Python code also to extend
it and I'm not sure about how it's with
dependencies with bouquet the problem
also was that the dependencies in the
front at one of sandbox so using the
Vega embed library it just depends on
Vega hambert and D free but Boccaccio's
also brings in some other front-end
tools dependency which also I used by my
front end task but bokya has used the
two years old version which is not
comparable with the future stuff the
question was how's feedback from the
users and for us it was quite good
because Vegas also really fast so the
homepage goes snap yeah we got a bit
faster and doing building your eyes
which also was a positive feedback from
the users I think the main positive
feedback we also got for was from the
front-end developers because we got rid
of this pipe and things they have they
have to run a flask app but that's all
they have just do flask run and then
they have a back-end which provides some
data that's order exposure to pipe now
or questions if you tried it with really
big datasets
no million points or so at the moment
the problem is with really big datasets
is that you have to pass this data in
JSON format to the browser you can also
pass it in CSV the the nice thing is I'm
in the arrow project and for your four
days ago Jake van de Blas who's doing
out here and a colleague of him appeared
in our arrow back tricking us okay we
wanted to integrate arrow into Vega how
how can we proceed with that and that's
maybe a thing that was going to happen
because there are other people who
blotting millions of points in the
browser using arrow but they're not
using Vega at the moment because Vega
has this much overhead that may happen
but with a million think a million could
work but more than a million will get
really slow so maybe relate to this when
you like if you zoom in do you need to
send new data or will we always use the
data it's already there so let's say
that byte on the pilot on the flask is
how you decide well I will like scale
down my data points like by grouping
them if I if I give the whole range but
if if I gotta zoom then I will resend
new data points is that possible or by
default if you zoom in it just zooms in
with the data that's in the browser so
you can build that it gets new data
points but that's not something that's
available out of the box there callbacks
available in the front-end library but
that's also something that's in the
front end reliably not in the
specification so that's needs a lot of
overhead time Thanks other questions
well let's think you were again
[Applause]